did you have a chance to watch the
jubilee over the weekend i wish i was
busy with mtv
well let me just tell you this it
continued with a star study concert
celebrating elizabeth 70 years on the
throne there were a lot of surprises but
they saved the best for last and once
again our royal correspondent katie
nichol she was right there in the mix
yesterday we finally saw our jubilee
queen in bright green on the balcony of
buckingham palace and there was some
royal baby news too pippa middleton
duchess kate's sister is pregnant with
her third child she showed off her
growing baby bump in green on saturday
that's when we got another surprise from
her majesty i keep mine in here
yup that's the queen in a video with
paddington beer e.t has learned the
sketch was shot in march and according
to a palace spokesman her majesty is
well known for her sense of humor and
the opportunity to invite a famous beard
to tea was just too much fun to miss
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
your majesty
mommy
also having a bit of fun prince charles
and william honoring the monarch during
the star-studded party at the palace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
queen with adam lambert kicked off the
performances sir rod stewart got the
royals singing sweet caroline and alicia
keys changed up the lyrics to empire
state of mind swapping new york for
closing out the night diana ross
performing her first uk live show in 15
years
[Music]
notably absent of course was william's
brother harry and his wife megan who
left early jetting back to the u.s right
after celebrating daughter lily bert's
first birthday
that's harry arriving in santa barbara
in the passenger seat with megan in the
back gifts were offloaded from their
private jet including a swing set which
may match the one previously gifted to
will and kate's kids the queen meant a
little bit her parents just released
this candid portrait from her birthday
which was celebrated at frogmore with
several family members but why did will
kate and their kids leave london on
lillabet's big day
the duke and duchess of cambridge
tweeted their well wishes to lilybet
while taking their children charlotte
and george on a previously scheduled
visit to wales
a source tells e.t the trip was simply a
coincidence and there was no intended
slight during rehearsals for a concert
at cardiff castle charlotte tried her
hand at conducting the band as they
played we don't talk about bruno the
siblings also made cupcakes for the
cardiff community and little louis
stealing the show again with his many
faces during sunday's finale parade
proving the royals just like the rest of
us kate had to calm her son louie down
who was taunting her with his tongue out
and this classic schoolyard move the
cambridges took to their official
twitter account and acknowledged all the
fun quote we had an incredible time
especially louie sunday's pageant cost
an estimated 18 million around 18
million people also took part in street
parties yesterday including supermodels
naomi campbell and kate moss while ed
sharon closed out the event
[Music]
yes it was the queen's jubilee but louis
was definitely the star of the show